porque las interrupciones en la cadena
de suministros y la logística de la
producción de cereales y semillas de
ucrania y rusia así como las
restricciones a las exportaciones rusas
tendrán y tienen importantes
repercusiones para la seguridad
alimentaria según la fao el temor de
este organismo de naciones unidas se
debe a que tanto ucrania como rusia son
uno de los mayores exportadores de
cereales de todo el mundo además de los
fertilizantes usados en los campos rusia
es el mayor vendedor de trigo del
planeta mientras que ucrania es el
quinto y ambos proporcionan el 19 por
ciento del suministro de cebada el 14
por ciento del trigo el 4 por ciento del
maíz del planeta y venden el 52 por
ciento del aceite de girasol todos estos
factores van a encarecer y encarecen
como ya estaba ocurriendo los alimentos
por otro lado del precio de la urea un
fertilizante nitrogenado esencial
aumentó un 300% en los últimos 12 meses
debido a la elevada demanda y también la
volatilidad del costo del gas natural de
la energía y por supuesto de esta guerra
que estamos viendo para ello entonces
quiero saludar en ese momento es
directora regional para américa latina y
el caribe del programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu gracias lola por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 atender nuestra invitación el
programa mundial de alimentos entonces
aseguró que la cadena de suministro
dentro de ucrania está colapsando le
pregunto cuál es la situación real
dentro de este país en guerra
bueno el programa mundial de alimentos
está extremadamente preocupado por
varias cosas una es por la cantidad de
personas que están en este momento tanto
desplazadas como fuera del país de
ucrania y están sufriendo inseguridad
alimentaria entonces estamos intentando
lo más que podemos para tener stocks de
alimentos dentro del país y fuera del
país para atender a estas personas en
coordinación con los países vecinos
también en este momento estamos
intentando enviar pues trenes camiones a
los lugares donde es posible pero claro
la cadena de suministros está rota en
algunas áreas donde debido a la crisis
del conflicto no se puede entrar entrar
en este momento pero estamos llegando a
mucha gente ya y el objetivo es llegar a
3 millones de personas que pensamos que
son los más vulnerables en este momento
claro también cuáles podrían ser estos
países más afectados por la ruptura de
la cadena de suministros ustedes
mencionan por ejemplo a naciones como
yemen y como como el líbano por qué
bueno el tema como tú bien dijiste es
rusia y ucrania son unos grandes
productores y también exportadores de
trigo de maíz de de aceite de girasol o
productos de girasol entonces en
nuestros en nuestra cadena alimentaria
el programa mundial de alimentos
necesita esos productos y compramos
enormes cantidades de estos productos
para todos nuestros programas en el
mundo por ejemplo el año pasado
compramos 780 mil toneladas de trigo en
estos países y también 91 mil toneladas
de
leguminosas entonces teniendo en cuenta
esto si los productos están bloqueados
como están en este momento en los
puertos en este momento estamos viendo
que hay
millones y millones de toneladas
bloqueadas en puertos y almacenes tanto
en rusia como ucrania y no los podemos
exportar al resto del mundo esto
significa uno que nuestros programas
comunitarios más grandes que son yemen
siria y afganistán pueden tener
problemas para definir todos los
productos nosotros encontremos una
alternativa y segundo que los precios
y estamos extremadamente preocupados por
que veamos algo como el 2008 y en
algunos productos ya estamos viendo
precios según la fao como semejantes al
2008 incluyendo precios del transporte
de los combustibles lola cómo afecta
esto los programas humanitarios y
ustedes tienen para nuestra región
américa latina y el caribe
bueno en américa latina y el caribe la
verdad es que compramos mucho en américa
latina y el caribe y también hacemos
muchas transferencias monetarias sin
embargo estamos extremadamente
preocupados porque lo que compramos se
produce mucho en la región pero también
como bien hablaste es el peso de los
fertilizantes y el transporte de los
fertilizantes está aumentando ya que
rusia ucrania y bielorrusia son grandes
productores y es teniendo en cuenta esto
no sabemos cuánto va a haber para las
conciencias las próximas cosechas en la
región también estamos muy preocupados
por los pequeños productores porque como
programa de alimentos estamos comprar lo
más cerca que podemos de nuestros
proyectos en latinoamérica el caribe
para fomentar así los mercados locales y
asegurarnos que las mujeres y hombres
que producen localmente consigan
realmente una seguridad alimentaria y
acceso al mercado esto puede verse en
graves problemas este año debido a la
falta de fertilizantes ya lo vimos un
poco desde ccoo bien tanto el joven se
consiguió mantener gracias a que se
mantuvieron las fronteras abiertas
hubo apoyo de los gobiernos hubo apoyo
de redes de protección social pero este
año no sabemos cómo va a actuar y
estamos haciendo todo tipo de análisis
claro lola y le pregunto entonces ante
esta situación han ustedes pensaba
buscar a proveedores alternativos y si a
lo mejor estos proveedores alternativos
pueden suplir la demanda que ustedes
pues lo que ustedes querían y lo que
ustedes le compraban a rusia y ucrania
si realmente estamos en ello a nivel
global así como a nivel regional porque
mira en en el año 2022 nuestro plan era
asistir a 137 millones de personas en el
mundo y en latinoamérica y el caribe
planifica vamos a atender 8 millones de
personas eso son las personas que están
en más inseguridad alimentaria es
esencial que reciban un paquete
alimentario o un subsidio una
transferencia para que la puedan comprar
ya que no tienen capacidad bastante
ingresos para acceder al mercado
entonces tenemos que encontrar una
solución urgentemente se está trabajando
en muchas áreas incluyendo donde
encontrar mercados alternativos de trigo
maíz y soya y de girasol y también
estamos trabajando cómo mejorar el costo
del transporte porque los fletes también
normalmente inflados por ejemplo aquí en
nuestra región de latinoamérica el
caribe en el 2019
pagamos aproximadamente 70 dólares por
tonelada métrica que movíamos ahora
estamos pagando 7 veces más hasta hace
550 dólares lo que significa que a veces
vamos a pagar más por el flete que por
la comida
tenemos que buscar también soluciones
alternativas